I don't really know what artisanal means
I thought I don't know what it means
either but I'm totally a sucker for it
I'm not gonna lie I don't really buy
groceries I got shopping like once a
month and I just eat out all the time
and I have a horrible lifestyle I think
it tastes the same I think it would
taste better I know it tastes better I
don't like the goal really number one
salty tastes like stuff I have like a
resume with my hot dog
super piccoli right I don't feel like
it's been like sitting in a jar for a
long time I think these pickles have
touched other foods just why I'm
inclined to think art is now number two
this one has a much richer green yeah
almost a fake looking green this one
looks more special yeah it's like more
colorful interesting this may be better
mmm this one's better but that could be
the preservatives I think this one's
artisinal I'm gonna go with - I want to
say - is artisinal my votes for number
two I say number two also ah because
this one looks more like organic number
one okay we're just going at this okay
I'm going that makes sense
oh oh okay well it smells like Mayo we
did just eat mayonnaise with a spoon
it's so warm it uh-huh
this is so oily it just tastes like
olive oil and mayo mixed together I'm
definitely leaning towards this one as
the artisinal one there's just a more
more density of flavors so number two
that's it's much better this one too is
better to eat better and two is the one
that we've always have does smell like
anything that's weird
lots of high fructose corn syrup in here
see this one I was just gonna go back
for a second
mmm yeah definitely I just know yeah
number one yeah one is artisanal right
thank you yes all right
yeah okay so what are we what are we
looking for here
artisanal maple syrup probably smells
more like maple trees okay
wow that's like rich taste typical to me
I don't know it just was like I could I
mean so far I would say this is like the
more expensive one because you can sort
of taste um the meatball yeah no crap
this is spicier yeah this is that's
definitely sweeter number one yeah I'm
ashamed to say I can't tell the
difference this sounds also delicious
also this one has a little more untrim
imma appeal to it I think definitely one
I'm just going with one because the two
has these weird bubbles in it mhm I
think two is artisinal yeah I'm gonna
say number one is the expensive one I'm
gonna say number one two expensive one
ah see I just know one ah damn it what
what I do like organic ketchup more than
regular kitchen so this should be like
easy for should be hopefully so number
one it's got a real high surface tension
this is a red forty died right at its
best
it tastes like ketchup yeah McDonald's
ketchup absolutely yeah it tastes it
tastes sour it's like yeah it's like
sour sour ketchup acid
well processed food is horrible that's
what I'm learning through this I mean
it's not going to change my diet is just
whereas this one a thicker it's thicker
it's got this like mottled texture
rather than eerily smooth better
aftertaste
tastes like tomato sauce a little bit it
does taste like tomato sauce and it like
stays in your mouth yeah
Claire's not good I sorta I like it
actually like that yeah this isn't a
bottle that has the words ketchup on the
front no way she would do - I choose - I
like number one but I know number two is
to write one okay which myself I have on
number two also yeah I think - is
artisinal
I grew up eating this but the artist no
one tastes much better like I feel
better eating it I like the regular
store-bought ones better
I think cuz I'm used to it one day I'll
be very rich not only buy organic food
and you know organic peanut butter from
Whole Foods
but that's not my currently and hang out
with a you know corny Adriana
I'll always pay more because it's like I
read about it in a fancy magazine you
have to get the good ketchup